[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Thank you guys
all for coming today.
I would like to
present Ruth Whippman.
We're here today to talk about
her book, "America the Anxious,
Why Our Search for Happiness
is Driving Us Crazy
and How to Find It For Real."
As a quick introduction,
Ruth is a British journalist
and has contributed pieces
to "The New York Times,"
"The Guardian,"
"The Independent,"
and the "Huffington Post."
She previously worked for
BBC, where she was releasing
numerous documentaries.
And in her book,
she examines what's
gone wrong with
American happiness,
and why it is leading to such
an anxious, and ultimately,
unhappy society, and what
can be done about it.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a long-time Googler.
And yeah, so would you like to
tell us more about yourself.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Sure.
Yeah, well, we
moved to California
about six years ago from the
UK, and it was quite a culture
shock.
My background is in journalism.
And do you want me to tell
you a bit more about--
SPEAKER: Yeah, please.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: --what
prompted me to write the book?
SPEAKER: Exactly.
Yeah.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Well,
when we first got here,
we came because my husband got
a job working in a tech startup.
And it was quite a leap
into the dark for us.
And I had given up my job in
journalism back in the UK.
And every day he would shut
the door going off to work
and I'd have these 12
cavernous hours of time
to fill before I could have
an adult conversation again.
We had a young baby at the time.
So I was putting
myself out there
and trying to meet as
many people as I could.
Having lots of
random conversations
with people at the dry
cleaners, and the grocery store,
and in the park with my son.
And I found very quickly
that this strange thing
was happening.
I seemed to be having
the same conversation
over and over again.
Different people,
different situations,
different scenarios,
but the same topic
just kept on coming up.
And this was some variation
on this theme of happiness.
And people were talking
about happiness almost
as a real source of
anxiety in their lives.
People were asking these really
big questions of themselves.
Am I happy?
Am I happy enough?
Am I as happy as all my friends
that I see on social media?
Could I be happier if I
was following my passion?
But what is my passion?
All of this.
And there seemed
to be this real gap
between what people expected
in terms of their happiness
and how happy they
actually were feeling.
And so I was prompted--
I was really fascinated and it
was a real cultural difference,
because I think in the UK
happiness is a little bit
suspect.
You don't want to show too many
overt signs of being too happy.
So I wanted to look into it.
And what I found was that--
you would think, given the kind
of cultural focus on happiness
here in the States, and the
amount of money and time
and effort that people
put into becoming happier,
you would think Americans
would be the happiest people
on the planet.
But statistically, they
actually rank very, very far
down the list of happiness.
So that was my starting
point for writing this book.
I just wanted to find out
why, what's going wrong,
and how we can find out what
really makes for a happy life.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
One thing you define
it in the book
almost like a rat
race for happiness.
What did you mean
by that exactly?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
I mean the expression that
happiness-- rat race--
came to me when people
would talk about happiness
almost in the same
way that people
talk about going on a diet.
There's not much
pleasure involved in it.
But if I just read this book,
and do this meditation app,
and go to this--
write in my gratitude
journal, and be more mindful,
and be more positive, and be
more this, then I can be happy.
And it felt like it was
really a lot of hard work--
happiness.
There wasn't much
pleasure involved in it.
SPEAKER: And something
that's interesting-- you have
had all these
experiences, you've
talked to all these people
who seem to be filling
their life with all these
measures to become happier,
but when you look
at it statistically,
the United States may be one
of the least happy countries,
and also our happiness
levels really
haven't changed in
quite some time.
That's correct, right?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Right.
So when you look at the
actual data on this,
despite spending more time,
and money, and emotional energy
in trying to become
happier, compared
to other developed
nations, Americans
are some of the least happy
people in the Western world.
And actually, there was a study
that came out a year or so ago,
which actually put the
day-to-day contentment
of people in the US at
two places behind Rwanda.
I mean if you just think
about that for a moment,
Rwanda is a country
that suffered
a major collective
psychological trauma, but yet
people there are rating as more
content than American office
workers.
So that really
was a paradox that
made me want to know
more and find out
what was going wrong exactly.
SPEAKER: And are
there key differences
that you noticed specifically
for moving from the UK
to the United States?
Whatever that was.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: I
think that there
are a lot of differences
in the way that people
talk about happiness.
I think there's a
real focus in the US.
And I think this is a
good thing in many ways.
But there is a real
valuing of people
being positive-- people being
cheerful and positive all
the time and appearing happy.
Being happy and also looking
happy to everybody else.
And don't be a downer
and everything.
And I think in the
UK, maybe people
are a little bit more jaded.
And actually being
negative is almost part
of the culture in a way.
It's not expected that people
would have such a high level
of happiness all the time.
And people don't go after it
in quite such a relentless way,
I think.
SPEAKER: So let's take a
step back then and then talk
about the book for a second.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Sure.
SPEAKER: Could you give
us a brief quick outline--
I found it really
interesting how you went
about examining this rat race.
Could you give us a brief
outline of what you did?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
So I did lots of
different things.
I spent a lot of time--
I sampled quite a few of
the self-help offerings
that people are selling.
And I realized self-help
in this country
is a multibillion
dollar industry.
A lot of money is changing hands
in this pursuit of happiness
and this idea that we
can control our happiness
and make ourselves happier.
So I did the Landmark forum.
I don't know if any of
you have heard of that,
but it's a very popular
self-help weekend,
four-day course that's
incredibly intense.
And I went through everything
on the spectrum of emotion
while I was doing that
from sheer terror,
to depression, to anxiety,
to joy, to all of it.
I spent time with--
I went to Las Vegas
where I spent time in--
Tony Hsieh, who is
the CEO of Zappos,
the shoe retailer-- he has
a happiness city almost,
that he's set up in
downtown Las Vegas.
He's bought up a
whole lot of land
and is running it as a happiness
community based on principles
of positive psychology and
on the idea that you can
maximize people's happiness.
And that was a very
strange place to be.
And I spent time
with Mormons in Utah.
The Mormons actually
rate, statistically,
as the happiest
people in America.
And but actually what makes
this slightly more complex
is that they also
have the highest
rate of anti-depressant use.
So I was trying to unpick
what was going on there.
And I looked at the
workplace-- some trends
in happiness engineering
in the workplace.
I looked at parenting,
social media.
And I spent some time looking
at the academic research
on happiness, which frankly
was the most joyless part
of the whole endeavor.
Academic studies on happiness
are really quite dry.
SPEAKER: And so in listening
and reading the book,
it was really interesting to see
how you jumped from one topic
to the next in this overall
vision of what you perceive
the United States to be in terms
of this pursuit for happiness.
Which one of those
experiences did you
find to be the most revealing?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: That's
an interesting question.
I mean, I think, it's
hard to pick one.
I mean going to spend
some time at the Downtown
Project in the Las Vegas thing
that I was talking about where
this very, very wealthy tech
billionaire has brought people
from all over the United States
to live in this community
and work as entrepreneurs.
And there's this kind of
semi-communal living a lot
of it, where people live
and work in the same place
and they've maximized happiness
by putting the buildings
in certain places
in the square--
how many people per square foot.
And everything is so planned.
And one of the really
kind of shocking things
was in this so-called
happiness community,
they ended up having one
of the highest suicide
rates in the United States.
So I mean, that was a very
dark and awful tragic,
but also fascinating.
And I think it
had partly to do--
and a lot of the people
that were saying--
that it partly had to do
with this extreme pressure
to be happy all the time.
That I think really
stressed people out.
And that was the thing
that I kept coming back to.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
I think it's an interesting
topic too for discussion,
because in the tech world a lot
of what we're discussing today
is how can the
internet of things
influence your surroundings.
So if whether it's your home
or whether it's the city itself
that you live in, how can
being surrounded by technology
create a more fruitful
life, a happier life?
From your experience
was that something
that was relevant to the time
that you spent in Downtown?
Was technology ever present
and did it cause more happiness
or was it rather something
else that caused people
to commit suicide?
[LAUGHS]
RUTH WHIPPMAN: I mean all of
these things are quite complex.
I mean the Downtown Project--
I mean there was a slight
sense at the beginning
that they were going
to use happiness--
that they were going to use
technology even more to monitor
where people went.
And they had this
idea that everyone
was going to wear a
wristband to measure
how many social
interactions they had
and how happy they were.
And this technology
actually exists.
I mean, I found--
they weren't actually
using these wrist bands
in the Downtown
Project, but they
do use them in many companies.
This has become something
that your boss can monitor
how happy you are, and
how productive you are,
and how the two
relate to each other.
And there is something
very big brother-ish
and sinister about that.
I mean, I think in
terms of the way
that most people use
technology and the internet--
I mean it's no one thing.
I mean technology is
what you make of it.
And I think there's
good and bad in that.
I mean I looked at social media.
It was a big thing
that I looked at.
And I think that can
bring its own anxieties.
I think it raises
the expectations.
It's the way that we
use social media now--
Instagram, Facebook-- trying
to make our lives look--
it was almost like a
personal PR project--
your Facebook profile,
and how happy you look,
and here I am having
so much fun in all
these different situations.
And I think that in itself has
raised the stakes for anxiety
for many of us.
SPEAKER: One of the things
that I really laughed about
and I found it so
relevant to my life was--
two things.
First and foremost,
you're right,
social media becomes this PR--
it really it is your brand
in its own respective.
But then you also
mention in your book
that it's also creating a
sanitized version of your life
to a degree.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Right.
Right.
SPEAKER: And maybe
even replacing
some interpersonal communication
you have with other people.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Right.
I mean, it's kind of
become an arms race.
And I think we all do
it to a certain extent.
And I find myself
doing it, even having
written a book about this.
I find myself doing
the same thing.
Like, for instance, I
took my kids apple-picking
in a local orchard recently.
And frankly, the day
was kind of miserable.
I mean we did--
the kids were whining the
whole time, it was really hot,
everybody was bored, the
apples were all mushy.
And then the photo that ended
up on Facebook of this day--
the one probably millisecond
in the entire day
when everyone was
smiling and posing
and whenever-- that's
what ended up there.
And anyone looking
at that thing would
have thought oh, Ruth, what
a great day she's having.
And I wish my life
was like that.
Meanwhile, I'm just thinking
oh, thank god that's over.
And it's the way that
we curate our lives now,
I think it does give a very
unrepresentative picture
of what happiness looks like.
And I think that is adding
to this anxiety of my life
really should be like this and
somewhere here and this gap.
SPEAKER: That's very true.
One thing I wanted to
touch upon was really
diving into your experiences
with the self-help community.
The Landmark forum is the
pinnacle one in your book.
Then there's a few other ones
at some elementary schools
as well.
And you do a really
good job of just bashing
on these forums
and these pundits
and just really
examining in a crude way,
almost how they're
swindling people.
What do you think
from what you saw
attracted people to the forum
and then also to even re-up
and say, I'll do level 2.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Right.
Well, I mean, this thing it's--
I mean I think that
naturally the type of people
who are attracted
to self-help tend
to be in the more
vulnerable end of things.
I mean, you don't go
on a self-help course
when your life is
already brilliant.
So you're already
dealing with people
who have issues and problems.
And this is a business.
I mean there is a lot
of money changing hands.
And it is in these
people's interest
to get as much money as
possible, which is not
to say that everybody in
the self-help industry
is some kind of
charlatan or fraudster
or whatever that's trying
to steal your money.
But I think there is an
element of that in this thing.
And I think the
Landmark forum is
a very, very intense program.
I mean, you're in this room,
it's a conference room,
and you're there
for very long hours,
you have very limited breaks.
And it's till 10
o'clock at night
and you're just getting
all this information.
And everybody is sharing
these incredibly dark moments
from their lives and you
feel very, very vulnerable.
And then they come in at
just the crucial moment
and say, well, maybe you'd like
to sign up for the next course.
And you're weeping about
you've had a terrible childhood
or whatever, and you're
like, OK, whatever,
whatever, I'll pay
whatever it takes.
It was a very powerful
emotional experience
being there and not
necessarily for the good.
That's for sure.
SPEAKER: Was there ever a time--
because I imagine in
researching this book,
you wanted to get as much
information as you could.
Was there ever a time
where you're like,
I don't want to go to
another self-help forum and--
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER: --but you
forced yourself to do so.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
I mean it's funny that when
it came to the Landmark forum
I actually did the Landmark
forum before the book.
It went the other way around.
And that was one of the things--
everyone had told me do
this thing, it's amazing,
it's amazing, amazing,
amazing, you've got to go.
And it was almost
the other way around.
I did the forum
thinking just because I
wanted to be happier--
I was kind of lonely
in my new country--
and I went and that
was part of what
led to the book rather
than the other way around.
But yeah, I did a lot
of this mindfulness
workshops, I did meditation,
I did various things.
And a lot of the time I
did this sort of thing,
and I thought oh,
gosh, not another one.
But at the same time, I wanted
to be open to these things.
I didn't want to start
from the position
that this is all a load
of rubbish and just--
I wanted to see what actually
worked and what didn't.
SPEAKER: And you bring
up a good point, too.
And that the majority
of people that are maybe
going to a self-help forum or
reading a book about self-help
are in actual need
of help or rather
are seeking some
kind of answers.
From the people that
you interacted with
and people that
you met, did they
find answers in these books?
Did they experience some
kind of transformation?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Well, I
think a lot of people do.
I mean, there's an atmosphere,
like a tent revival
in a lot of these places.
Where it's like oh, yes,
and everyone gets whipped up
into this kind of frenzy.
And then the most successful
people in this industry
are the people who can
really prey on those emotions
and whip people
up into a frenzy.
And I think people do
feel very transformed,
but then one of the
depressing statistics
is that the most likely
customer of a self-help book
is somebody who's bought
another self-help book
within the last 18 months.
So there's obviously
something where
people get on a kind of spiral
and none of these things
are actually providing quite
the answers that the people are
hoping for.
And I think you raised
an interesting point
when you said, these are
people who need help.
There's something about
in this whole idea--
so it's a very American
idea in a way, this idea
that happiness is something
that we can control.
That self-help rather than
helping others, or that help
should be provided
from some other source,
so that you are
entitled to help.
It's like go out and help
yourself and pull yourself up
by your bootstraps and
make yourself happier.
I don't know if you've ever
seen these memes that say,
happiness is a choice.
It's quite a common phrase here.
It's almost like if you don't--
it's your responsibility
to make yourself happier,
which can be quite anxiety
inducing in itself.
SPEAKER: And that's definitely
an interesting point
you bring up in the book,
which is that in America it
seems that we're really seeking
happiness and isolation.
And is that starkly different
from your experiences
not having lived in the country?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Well, so
this is one of the things
that I kept coming back
to in my research, which
is that pretty much every
piece of research that's ever
been done into human
happiness and no matter
how much all these studies
all contradict themselves
in other ways,
there is one factor
that we know is the single
biggest cause of happiness.
And that is our social
connections, our relationships
with other people.
But yet, the self-help industry
and our conception of happiness
is moving more and more and more
towards being about the self.
And a lot of the activities
that we're taking part in now,
like meditation, like
mindfulness, like yoga, they're
all about having a very
private emotional experience,
about looking within your
soul, and being internal,
rather than external.
And I think that's one
of the real problems.
I think that was one of the
key findings that really
made me think, OK,
this might be where
we're going slightly wrong.
And I think it's a trend that's
true in other Western countries
as well.
We are living increasingly
isolated lives.
But I think in America, there's
a very individualistic culture
and I think that our
approach to happiness
is me in my happiness journey
and my quest for happiness
and how can I make
myself happier,
which is probably going about
it in slightly the wrong way.
SPEAKER: I found it
really fascinating
to listen to the stories
that you'd bring up.
Specifically, around yoga and
meditation, how people would be
say doing four or five yoga
classes a week to try and get
that sense of fulfillment and
happiness and mindfulness.
And it opened a door to
maybe a different world
than I would see.
Because I don't know many
friends that are doing yoga
on a day-to-day--
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Doing so much.
SPEAKER: --basis much,
in order to feel content
or in order to build
that happiness.
From what you saw, do
you think that maybe--
I don't know if extreme is
the right word, but were there
extreme examples of the seeking
out of people's happiness.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
I mean, I don't want to
give the wrong impression
that I think that yoga is the
cause of all the problems.
[LAUGHTER]
We're not talking about that,
because obviously that's
not true.
But I think it's about
a kind of mindset.
I think California is
the world headquarters
of self-actualisation, isn't it?
So I think the things that you
see here in California maybe
are a little more extreme
than you would see elsewhere.
But these trends do hold
true across the country.
You think about Oprah and
the influence that she's had.
And it's all about my
personal happiness journey
and my own responsibility
for my happiness.
And a lot of these they hold
yoga mindfulness meditation.
What I've come to think of
is the spiritual industrial
complex.
I mean that is worth about
$20 billion to the economy.
I mean, it's a lot of
money changing hands here.
It's very popular.
SPEAKER: So these
self-help forums,
these self-help books
are to a degree useful,
but maybe they don't hold
all the answers for us.
From your research, what do
you think could lead Americans
to a happier life?
RUTH WHIPPMAN:
Well, I think that
what I found just again and
again and again, whether that
was through the field work or
the academic staff or whatever.
It's that the key
to happiness really
is in relationships
and other people.
And you know I say
this all the time.
And one of the most common
responses that I get
is people say, well,
that's fair enough,
but that doesn't apply to
me, because I'm an introvert
and I hate other people, and I'd
rather just sit in my basement
and never talk to anyone.
But actually, all the
research supports the fact
that the importance
of social connection
is just as true and
important for introverts
as it is for extroverts.
It might manifest in a
slightly different way.
It might not be going
to lots of huge parties
and being the
center of attention.
But still the importance of
having supportive relationships
is just--
and also it's not just for our
happiness, it's for our health.
Low social connection
or loneliness
carries with it a risk
of premature death
comparable to that of smoking.
And it's about
twice as dangerous
to be lonely as
it is to be obese.
And you think how much money
and effort we put into dieting
and not being obese, when
actually here's an answer which
is so important right there?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
There was an interesting part
at the end of the book talking
about the genetic
component of happiness
and how you have this
biological marker of where
you're going to always be happy
and then you can have variance.
Was there ever any
information or studies
that you found that showed
maybe that that fulfillment
and that biological marker
could be tweaked up.
Not necessarily change
at the baseline,
but social interactions
or the things
that made that marker move up--
I don't even know if it's
measurable to be honest.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
I mean, I think there's been
various ways to measure it.
And I think that
people generally
agree that there's a big
genetic component to happiness.
So people have a
happiness set point
that they keep returning to, but
you can work around it a bit.
Where the whole positive
psychology movement
has become slightly political,
slightly ideological,
is that it very much downplays
the idea of circumstances
on our happiness, and
very much plays up
the idea of individual control.
So there's a lot of
research now and a lot of it
is funded by a very right
wing biased organization.
This belief that we can--
it's this bootstraps
idea that we
can make ourselves happier
by trying all this stuff
and it's your responsibility.
And if you're not
happy, it's almost
like it is your own fault. And
downplays all these factors
like income, race, social
class, social projects.
Which actually is
not a fair reading.
I believe it's based on a
very, very flawed reading
of the data, and
actually circumstances
do make a huge difference.
SPEAKER: So maybe an
open-ended question is,
we have all these
things-- we have yoga,
we have meditation to
build mindfulness--
religion is something
that you discussed too
and that religious people
are statistically more happy,
but maybe in real life those
statistics don't necessarily
hit on the actual reality.
With all of these
things, how do they
get built into a happy
life while also maintaining
the social connections?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Well,
the religion thing
that you just mentioned
is really interesting,
because across the world
it's pretty robust finding
that religious people
do rate as happier
than non-religious people.
And I think the
temptation is to think
that that is because people
have this private belief in God
and this certainty that things
will be OK because there's
an afterlife or whatever.
But when you
control for the fact
that religious people have
much greater number and quality
of social connections--
when you control
for that in the studies,
the difference disappears.
So actually, the reason
why religious people
tend to rate as happier
than other people
is because they have such a
strong sense of community,
generally.
And when I went to spend
time with Mormons in Utah
that was a huge finding.
I was staying with
a Mormon family
and we were sitting
there for half an hour
in their living room.
And I think 10
different people stopped
by for drop off some
cookies or a cup of tea--
not a cup of tea,
they don't drink tea,
but that's my
Britishness talking.
But whatever, a
drink or something.
So I think it is that
sense of community that
really is at the
heart of why religion
does make people happier.
SPEAKER: And so maybe a
point for the audience
as guardians of
technology at Google
and arbiters of new things,
what recommendations
would you have to us as we
build technology for people?
From what you've seen
in terms of happiness,
and one of the key things
that we say at Google
is build something that
someone would love to use.
Almost like a
toothbrush experiences
is one thing-- it's that
you want them to use it
every single day, because
they love it so much,
it's so useful.
When we're building these things
what should we be considering?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Wow.
That's a big question.
[LAUGHTER]
If I knew that, I'd be making
a lot more money than I am now.
I think technology
is competitive,
because it can be a force
for connection and bringing
people together and it can also
be a force for isolating people
as well and keeping people
locked in their own smartphone
and not--
I mean this is not Google, but
I remember one of these moments
when I was researching
this book and I thought,
oh my god, this is the
end of civilization,
was when I downloaded a
happiness app to my phone.
And I went on to the
app store and there's
a 1,000 different options
for happiness apps
that you can download,
that will send you
pictures of sunsets, and
puppies, and beaches.
And there was this one
that would send you
pictures of your
own loved ones, so
that you could sit
looking at your phone,
scrolling through pictures
of your loved ones,
while presumably your actual
loved ones are looking
at pictures of you, maybe.
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
And I remember there
was this one time when
the one I downloaded
actually would send you
these positive
affirmations every hour
or so throughout the day and you
were supposed to repeat them.
So it was, I am beautiful or I
am enough, or whatever it was.
And I remember the problem
was every time my phone buzzed
when I got a message
from this thing,
I'd get that Pavlovian jolt of
ooh, someone sent me a message,
great.
Somebody wants to go
out and meet for coffee
or it's a friend or whatever.
And then it would
say, I am enough.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'd think I
just want to throw
the phone across the thing,
because the whole point is
I am not enough.
And I think if we are
really looking to an app
to make us happy then
something has gone wrong.
SPEAKER: And that's
hit a little bit
on the research you did
around social media.
Have you found that at
least in your research
that a lot of
people have replaced
those in-person connections,
those interpersonal connections
with your phone, with
your application?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
I think there's
quite good evidence
to show that that has
definitely happened.
And especially,
for the millennials
and younger generation,
I think there
is a lot of concern
over the fact
that people are
replacing real world
interactions with online ones,
smartphone things for sure.
SPEAKER: Cool.
Well, I think we're
going to open it up
to questions in the audience
and as well as on the Dory.
[INAUDIBLE] if you're
still in the room--
I think he has a mike
that he can pass around.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: I think
someone had one over here.
AUDIENCE: Hey, so one of the
topics that you pointed out
regarding this whole stress
of trying to be happy
is the whole self-help
community and whatever.
But also the other thing
that I'm curious about
is what about the
contribution of the family.
Because one other thing I see--
I could be wrong,
but my understanding
is also we are in this trend
where probably the kids are
being pampered or this
whole notion of having
any kind of negative emotion is
like oh, something is extremely
wrong, rather than just teaching
them it's just part of life.
And you need to just go
through it and teach them
how to handle it.
So how much is that
also contributing
in creating
generations of people
who are probably extremely
confused about what is right?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: It's
an excellent point.
I actually write a whole
chapter about parenting--
sorry, have I lost
my thing here?
Sorry.
Yeah.
I write a whole chapter in
the book about parenting
and exactly what
you're describing.
I think there's
this-- in the same way
that there is this feeling
that we can force ourselves
to be happy with
enough hard work,
there's also a parallel
feeling that we can build
this perfectly happy child.
That if we just make
every moment magical
and we take away
every negative sense
and every negative emotion,
prioritize positivity
above all else, then
we will turn out
these perfectly happy kids.
And it's backfiring
really badly.
I mean some of the
examples that I came across
when writing the book were
actually quite ridiculous
and humorous.
There was this one thing I
was so shocked by when I first
moved here was that a friend
of mine left her 2-year-old,
I think--
2 and 1/2 year old-- with
another mom, while she
went to run some errands.
And this woman, the other woman,
breastfed this friend's child.
this friend's 2-year-old
because she was crying.
It was this feeling
that this child
can't be distressed
for one moment
without someone stepping out--
I mean that's a very
extreme example.
But I think there is this
data that we've become or--
I'm a parent and I know
that I'm part of this,
and it's hard to
get away from it.
But yeah, we have become
these helicopter parents
who are micro-managing
our kids' lives.
And then the evidence is
showing that kids in college
now are actually suffering some
really serious mental health
problems.
Severe levels of anxiety,
depression, lack of resilience,
those kinds of things.
And I think those trends
are related for sure.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I took a class at Google
called search inside yourself
about a year ago.
I don't know if you call
it a self-help class,
it does include some meditation.
But I think the biggest
takeaway I had from it
was a piece of advice that was
don't aim for a happy life, aim
for a meaningful life.
So is that something
that you found is you
should look for meaning, instead
of looking for happiness?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah, so
I think it's really--
I mean I haven't
done that course,
so I can't speak to exactly
what was discussed there.
I think meaning is
obviously really important
and I think connection is the
thing that's most important.
I think in a way there's
this trend where meaning
has become the new happiness.
Everyone's texting
meaning, meaning, meaning,
and then it loses its meaning,
because what is meaning.
I mean, meaning is
something that is
different to everything else.
And I think when there's
this MacGuffin, this thing
that we're all supposed
to chase after, then it
becomes its own rat race.
But yes, I think you're
right in that it's
important to see what things
have value in our lives
and just for happiness to
be a byproduct of our lives.
And living a connected,
meaningful life,
rather than chasing after
happiness specifically.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You touched upon
briefly the connection
between religious
people being more happy
because of social gatherings.
Could you elaborate a bit
more on that correlation,
what exactly causes that?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Why
does social connection
cause religious people--
AUDIENCE: No, how religious
people become happy because
of their social gatherings?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: --because of
their social connections.
Yeah.
Well, I think that there's
lots of research that
shows that people who have
a religious affiliation
spend more time socializing
and being part of a community.
And it's not necessarily that
they go on more dinner dates
or whatever, but it is that
if you have a religious place
where you go every week--
if you go to church or a mosque
or a synagogue or whatever--
that's very much
based on community.
And it's based on this
shared understanding
that people are responsible
for each other's welfare
and people will look
out for each other.
Not every religious
community is like that,
but I think that's a baseline.
And so people-- and
there's research
that shows that people
who are religious
are more likely to do
things like give blood,
and more likely to be
involved in community events,
to have more social events
per week than other people.
And I think that's why when you
control for that, when you take
that out of the equation,
then actually religious people
aren't any happier
than anybody else.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
Thank you.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So hey,
thanks for coming.
So you've been talking all
about the happiness aspect,
but you also mentioned
the term self-actualized.
And I was curious
of your perspective
on how you view the
difference between those two.
And to the point about a life
of trying to find meaning,
but about an effort to try and
get to better know yourself
through that
self-actualized review.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
So I think it's about balance,
because obviously getting
to know who you are
and becoming the best
self that you can be-- all of
those things are important.
And to work out
who you are and how
to work with that, that's
very, very important.
But I think what's
happened in America
is that the balance has
somehow got out of whack.
So we're putting
self-actualisation
above connection.
So the idea is that we engineer
happiness from the inside out.
That if you can perfectly
know yourself and understand
yourself--
I don't know if you've
heard this phrase,
happiness comes from within.
It's actually impossible to
get a result on a Google search
that tells you the
opposite, because I typed it
in that happiness--
I was going to do some--
at one point I was thinking
of doing some slides for this
and I typed in meme
happiness comes from within.
You got 1,000 results of all
these different memes saying
variations on this.
If you type in meme
in an image search,
happiness comes
from other people,
every single result seemingly or
at least on the front page that
comes back says, happiness does
not come from other people,
happiness comes from within.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's almost
like-- and so I think
the balance has got wrong.
So I'm not saying
that people should not
try to understand themselves,
reflect on themselves,
all of that.
That's obviously
important, but I
think the emphasis has
gone wrong somewhere.
I think if we make
connection and other people
are starting point
and then throw
in a bit of
self-actualization, rather
than having the balance
so skewed the other way.
Thanks.
Oh, hey.
AUDIENCE: So you were
talking about the importance
of social connections.
I think there are two
types I can imagine.
First, there are, for
example, close friends
who I spend a lot of
time interacting with
and I have deep connection.
And then there are just
people I barely know.
So it's just hard to
have many close friends,
because it takes a lot of time.
But you can have a lot of
people you barely know.
Is there any distinction which
type of relationships is more--
what's the difference
between them
and how do they influence
happiness in different ways?
Close relationships
and more meaningful
or just know as
many people you can?
[LAUGHTER]
RUTH WHIPPMAN: So both
are actually important,
surprisingly.
So it goes without
saying, I think,
that close friendships
and really supportive
relationships are more
important than the women who
sells you your newspaper
in the morning or whatever.
And that's really the key is
focusing on a few very close
supportive relationships.
But there is pretty
good evidence
to show that having lots of--
there is a technical term
for it-- but small social
connections also.
And being part of
a wider community
and feeling invested
in a community
also has a big impact on
our happiness as well.
So just feeling that
we're part of something
bigger than ourselves, I think.
So I think in
aggregate it might not
be that every single one
of those little connections
really is that meaningful,
but overall, I think
they can make a big difference.
SPEAKER: And I thought there
was an interesting point
in the book, not to give
too many details away,
but you quote Thomas Jefferson
and the pursuit of happiness.
And your interpretation
it's not so much
pursuing this inward
happiness, which
is perfected from all
my self-actualization,
but rather pursuing
a happiness which
makes you part of a
community and makes
you part of that larger whole.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yes.
I mean, I think that's pretty
clear that the founding fathers
weren't really thinking about a
self-help workshop when they--
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, that's taking
it to an extreme.
But yes, they were talking about
civic engagement and community
and that was very much being
part of a larger thing.
SPEAKER: Cool.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: One more.
I wonder if you upon writing
your book, if you touch on that
or what would you think
about-- or if you've noticed,
I'm not from here either.
And I wonder if you
noticed that there
seems to be some bragging
around mentioning or just
even implying that you're busy.
And people-- I find it very hard
here to just call a friend up
and say, hey, are
you up for a beer?
It's almost
virtually impossible.
And where I come from,
it's like we're adults,
we have these lives,
but it's just easier.
And I have almost become
that myself too, where--
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Everything
is great and wonderful idea.
AUDIENCE: --And the kids,
and I work full time.
And so yeah, it's also
hard for me sometimes.
But I get the sense
too, sometimes
that I feel this inner pride
of saying, well, no I'm busy,
and tonight can't
make it work or not.
And I'm like, yeah,
I'm a busy person.
And then I'm like,
I feel like shit.
I haven't had a beer in
a long time with anyone.
And I don't know.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
I mean it's so easy to
put just socializing down
to the absolute bottom of
the priority list, isn't it?
I mean, if you have a full
time job, you work hard--
I think, there's this--
I mean, we didn't
actually talk about this,
but it's something that
I touched on in the book.
That now what used to be
called work-life balance,
they're now calling
work-life integration,
which just makes my heart sink.
[LAUGHTER]
This seems to be more work.
That you have to have your
phone on all the time,
that you are answerable,
you're always on the clock.
And that we're merging all
these parts of our lives.
So there's very little
socializing or communicating
or whatever with friends
that is totally free of work
and free of
responsibilities in the way
that perhaps it used to be.
And I mean there's
this really chilling--
I thought chilling
statistic, which is the--
I don't know if you've heard of
the American time use survey,
but they just categorize
how people literally spend
every moment of their day.
And every activity
that you can think
of-- working, sleeping,
driving, having sex, whatever--
is all categorized.
And there's a category
on the survey called
socializing and communicating.
And it doesn't just
cover the good stuff.
So it's not just the
lovely heart to heart
that you have with
your best friend
or this adoring conversation
with your boyfriend
or girlfriend.
It's all the arguing, the
nagging, the bitching,
the whining, everything,
all thrown in together.
So as long as there's more
than one adult present
and it's not an incidental
part of something else.
Does anyone want
to hazard a guess
how much time we spent
on that category per day,
the average American?
AUDIENCE: 30 minutes.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
It's about 30 minutes a day.
So put another way, we know this
is the single most important
pillar of our
happiness, but yet we
spend 23 and 1/2 hours
out of every day not
doing that, doing something
completely different.
So I found that pretty scary.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for your talk.
Did you happen to see the
article in "The New York Times
Magazine" this last weekend?
It was called, "The
Kids Who Can't."
Which is like a mean title.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Oh,
I don't think so.
AUDIENCE: It was about
anxiety with millennials,
and especially, the
youngest millennials.
It was saying that-- it was
talking about this phenomenon.
So first of all,
I wondered if you
came across this
in your research,
anxiety being a bigger
problem with younger people?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yes.
Definitely.
AUDIENCE: And then have any
guesses of how to explain it,
it mentioned the social media
phenomenon, which I think
is right on the money
and you touched on that.
But another thing it
talked about was how--
I don't love this word, but it
said that the youngest people
are being coddled in the
sense that it's common now
if a kid is feeling
anxious that they're just
allowed to stay home from
school or that they have
their own dedicated
entrance to avoid
the stressors of the
main entrance at school.
And that was one of the
ideas that was put forward
as to why this is actually
having a negative effect
and keeping them in
this spiral of anxiety.
So I wondered what you
thought about that?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
I think that's absolutely right.
I mean, and I notice
it in myself as well.
I have two kids.
And my oldest son, he goes to
this drama group on a Thursday,
and he decided he doesn't like
it and he doesn't want to go.
And that he's got some
anxiety around that.
And instantly I think,
ooh, we've got to stop,
he doesn't have to go.
Why should he have
to go to that?
And it's very easy to think--
and I was about to pull
him out of this thing
and I go what on
earth am I doing?
I mean, and I look back at
my childhood and probably
a good 70%, 80% of the
stuff that I didn't really
want to be doing that much
and nobody was suggesting
that I would not be
doing it because of that.
And there's a
balance and whatever.
And I think it is good that we
consider kids' feelings more
now and that we
consider their emotions
and treat them as important.
And I do think that.
But absolutely, I think there
is this tendency and this idea
that everything has to be
magical and wonderful for kids
and that we remove negative
experiences from their path.
That is very damaging for sure.
AUDIENCE: How you doing?
Thanks for coming.
So my question
actually in relation
to that right there along
with the gentleman's
question over here about
sharing the connection and also
time usage.
So you talk about the sense
of community obviously
and to go along with these
younger generations being
a little more hyperactive or
stuck in these social media
and everything.
It seems to be a stereotype of
millennials that they're ADD,
they can't keep their
attention for anything.
So this idea of fragmentation
of not only your work and life
balance and everything, but
also your personal interests.
Do you find any correlation
between simplification
or really focusing on a
specific interest of yours
in regards to this
idea of having
too many communities
or too many friendships
that you don't actually get the
value out of it that you might?
Or is there a threshold
or correlation
to this idea that some of
these less developed countries
have less things to worry
about-- not necessarily
less things to worry about
and very important things
to worry about-- but this
idea that maybe they're just
not over-exerting where
their interests lie
and trying to do too much
or have too many communities
to really get invested in.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah,
and too much choice.
And I think we live in this
very consumerist world where
we have so much choice for
everything all the time.
And I think that can
sometimes be paralyzing.
That if you can be anything--
if we are all told, be
whatever you want to be,
follow your passion, find your
path, you can do anything.
I think sometimes you think,
oh my god, I can't do anything,
because it's just the
expectation is so high of what
happiness should look like.
And so many choices, so
many demands on our time
and attention, I
think absolutely
that it can be quite paralyzing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sorry,
just a quick follow-up.
Meaning, more
specifically, do you
think that there's
value in trying
to find a few
interests, as opposed
to just diversifying that a bit?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Lots
of different things?
That's interesting.
Yeah, I don't know.
I didn't look into
that specifically,
but I think that probably
depends on the individual
as well.
I think some people really have
a very deep and abiding passion
for one thing and that
really brings them happiness
and meaning to follow that.
And other people will try
lots of different things
throughout the course of life.
And same with friendships.
I think somebody over
here asked about-- you
asked about is it one
handful of close friends
or is it knowing lots
and lots of people.
And I think that is to do
with individual personality,
really what it comes down to.
SPEAKER: Cool.
Any more live questions?
If not, we can go to
the Dory for one or two.
AUDIENCE: We have one
more live question.
Hi.
I was actually
curious about what
you found when you were
researching about meditation.
Because I actually, I'm like
a natural born cynic generally
when it comes to
things like this.
But I went to a talk here
actually last month--
this guy named Daniel Gorman.
And it was really interesting
and actually skewed me
towards--
he came with a neuroscientist.
And they basically
had done research
where meditation and this
practice of mindfulness--
there was data done where they
looked at the brains of monks
and it showed that it
actually decreased stress
and there was just--
SPEAKER: And that's
actually the same book
we were talking about before.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah, before.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: "Altered Traits?"
SPEAKER: Yeah.
"Altered Traits."
AUDIENCE: And so I
guess I was curious
in your own findings, this is--
RUTH WHIPPMAN: So
this is a really--
this has been one of the most
controversial things actually--
this whole thing
about meditation.
Every time I ever
bring up meditation,
I get a million emails
from angry meditators
all over the world wanting
to run me out of town.
[LAUGHTER]
So I think there's
a few things there.
I think neuroscience is
much more complicated
than popular neuroscience
would allow us to believe.
So when we say, something
changes the brain,
it sounds amazingly
impressive, but pretty much
everything we do
changes the brain.
So from going to the bathroom
or to just sitting here
now to hearing your questions.
Everything we do
changes the brain,
because that's the
nature of the brain.
But so meditation and
mindfulness-- there
have been many
thousands of studies
done into the effects
of these things.
And the results have been, I
would say from my experience,
that not that there are no
effects of these things,
but they have been quite
strongly over-hyped.
So there was a
meta-analysis that
came out a year
or two ago, which
looked at all of these studies
and found that out of something
like 1,800 studies,
only 40 of them
actually had a controlled
comparison group.
So I don't know how much
people know about how
these kind of studies work.
But comparing a
group of people who
meditates to a group of
people who don't do anything,
isn't really a fair
comparison because there's so
many other factors
that could be going on.
There could be
placebo effect, it
could be the effect of having
a social connection, whatever.
When meditation is compared
to a control group where
they are doing
something comparable,
a reasonable control group,
meditation performs no better
and often worse than
something like exercise,
listening to spiritual
audiotapes, any kind of sham
control where you're
just putting something
to be a controlled condition.
So I think we need to
approach it with caution.
Which isn't to say
that for many people
it's an extremely meaningful
and important part of their day
and something that they
really get a lot from.
And that's great.
But I think once we
start rolling it out
as the answer to
everything, then that's
where it becomes problematic.
AUDIENCE: Sorry
one more question.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Sure.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So while
you're writing this book
and doing research
was there anything
that you found was effective?
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
I mean, I think it comes back--
this is just keep banging
on about the same thing.
But really it does come down
to connecting with other people
and doing that in a way
that's most meaningful to you.
But literally
spending more time--
seeing that we
spend half an hour
of our day socializing,
communicating,
as opposed to three
hours watching television
or being on the
internet or whatever,
and actually just trying
to up those minute.
To just spend more time doing
it and nurture the relationships
that we have.
I think that really is far
and away the best thing you
can do for your own happiness.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, to
clarify, I meant out
of all these kind
of self-help things.
Yeah.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
It's an interesting-- I think
a lot of these self-help things
that I did, there were one
or two points within them
that were interesting and
that I took away and thought
about some more.
And there were things
in the Landmark forum,
there were things
from mindfulness
that I think in certain
situations can be useful.
But I think, overall, any
one package of solutions,
I think is usually
over-promising quite heavily.
And so there was no one
brick or apple, course,
or whatever, that I could say
OK, well, the answer is this.
Because it didn't really
feel that way to me.
SPEAKER: Any more
live questions?
Cool.
We'll go to one of the
Dory questions then.
When measuring happiness, how
do you correct to the others--
there's a question--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
When measuring
happiness, how do you
correct for cultural differences
in what being somewhat very et
cetera happy?
I guess how do you add a
measure for cultural differences
when looking at happiness.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Yeah.
That's a really
interesting question.
I mean, there's a lot
of research on this,
because people in
different cultures
define happiness in
slightly different ways.
And I think people in
the West, tend to favor--
there's a word for
it, which has gone
from my mind-- but very
high energy emotions
like exhilaration, excitement,
real extreme emotions.
And I think maybe in
some other cultures,
they value a karma
contentment or whatever.
There was some really
fascinating research
that came out of UC
Berkeley recently,
which looked at how
people defined happiness
in different countries
around the world.
And A, how they defined it, and
then B, how happy they were.
And they found that in parts
of East Asia and in Russia,
I think, that people
defined happiness
in a much more collective way.
So they didn't really
see it as a kind
of individual pursuit in the
same way that we do in the US.
But they saw it more as a
socially orientated endeavor.
And for those people,
the more they--
if you defined
happiness in that way,
the more you pursued happiness,
the happier you became.
Whereas in the US, where
people define happiness
in a more individualistic way,
the more you pursue happiness,
the less happy you become.
So it's the opposite way.
SPEAKER: Super fascinating.
Cool.
Well, hey, thank
you for coming here
and thank you for
speaking with us.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: Oh,
thanks for having me.
It's been such a pleasure.
SPEAKER: It was
really wonderful.
RUTH WHIPPMAN: It's been great.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]